Horror fans have a lot to look forward to
over the next couple of years, with a growing
slate of sequels to smash hits, original projects
from trusted filmmakers, and even a couple
of exciting remakes on the rise.
2019 in particular looks to be a strong year
for the genre, so let's take a look at what
the kind-of-distant future will bring for
fright fans.
An American Werewolf in London
John Landis' landmark 1981 film established
him as a daring filmmaker with a strong visual
style and proved that he could successfully
blend gut-wrenching horror with comedy.
So, remaking An American Werewolf in London
might seem like a risky proposition for most
filmmakers.
But with the original auteur's son, Max, is
ready to take on the task, and he has his
father's blessing … sort of.
The elder Landis told Collider:
"I know it won't be as bad as An American
Werewolf In Paris, which was sh-t."
"Oh, be serious, would you?!"
Firestarter
Stephen King's Firestarter, a story about
a young girl with powerful pyrokinetic abilities
on the run from sinister government agents,
was adapted in 1984 with a young Drew Barrymore
in the lead.
While it's one the more faithful adaptations
of King's work, it hasn't aged perfectly,
so Blumhouse Productions is ready to give
the story a fresh new look.
One potential hiccup is that screenwriter
Akiva Goldsman is attached to direct.
Goldsman had a pretty major setback in 2017
when his screenplay for King's Dark Tower
failed to resonate with fans, but maybe he'll
turn things around with the new Firestarter.
It: Chapter Two
An even stronger Stephen King story in the
pipeline is the sequel to It.
The first chapter blew everyone away at the
box office, but Warner Bros. didn't greenlight
the second installment until they were absolutely
sure the film would be a hit.
Which means even though fans are clamoring
for a follow-up, there's still a lot of work
to be done.
Director Andy Muschietti is all but guaranteed
to return and says that the film will center
around the adult lives of the Losers as they
return to Derry to battle Pennywise... but
that we can expect to see all of those cute
kiddos from the first film, too.
It: Chapter Two is scheduled to hit theaters
on September 6th, 2019.
The Crooked Man
In addition to a new installment of The Conjuring,
2019 will also deliver another spin-off-slash-sequel
in The Crooked Man.
Based on one of the creepiest scenes from
The Conjuring 2, the film is expected to flesh
out the Crooked Man's backstory.
Between this, The Nun, and the continued chills
brought on by the Annabelle series, the Conjuring
universe is expanding into even scarier new
territory with every take.
Untitled Wizard of Oz movie
The Wicked Witch of the West is pretty frightening,
and goodness knows the world of L. Frank Baum
got wild in Return to Oz.
But now New Line Cinema is ready to see Oz
get even darker with a Wizard of Oz-centric
horror film.
The film will be written by newcomer Mike
Van Waes who's already showed some promise
in Hollywood with a black list script called
Hammerspace.
With all the anthropomorphic creatures and
conniving wizards already lurking around Oz,
it's not too hard to imagine the world getting
very, very grim.
"I even scare myself!"
Untitled Joss Whedon WWII film
Joss Whedon has been tied up in the realm
of superheroes lately, but he's still got
the gift of making edgy horror fare.
In 2019, he's returning to the fright fold
at last with a new historical horror film.
He told Complex:
"It's as dark as anything I've ever written.
It's a historical fiction-slash-horror movie
about a time when the world was going insane."
Whedon went on to discuss the "eerie" parallels
he uncovered between 1930s Germany and the
modern-day United States, so count on this
one to be creepy and a little too timely for
comfort.
The Blob
The 1958 low-budget horror classic The Blob
has already gotten the remake treatment once,
in 1988.
That version was pretty inessential, but with
Samuel L. Jackson and Halle Berry reportedly
starring in a new take, things are about to
get even quirkier.
Action director Simon West has long been attached
to the project, but we'll have to wait to
see how The Blob takes shape.
But with Jackson on board to star, we can
probably count on some wonderfully weird one-liners.
"I have had it with these motherf----ing snakes
on this motherf---ing plane."
Glass
If you haven't seen Split yet, spoiler alert.
You may want to skip ahead.
Still there?
"Oh, okay."
Split was certainly anchored by James McAvoy's
mesmerizing performance, but it's the film's
last act that really sticks the landing.
In the final scene, Bruce Willis makes an
unexpected return as David Dunn, the hero
of 2000's Unbreakable, and ties the world
of the Beast into the world of Samuel L. Jackson's
Mr. Glass.
M. Night Shyamalan has never been a sequel
guy.
So, it was a shock to see that those two films
are not only connected, but that a third installment
of the Unbreakable series called Glass is
on the way, too.
The cast will feature Willis, Jackson, McAvoy
and Anya Taylor-Joy all reprising their roles,
and it will be the final installment of the
dark superhero trilogy that has suddenly taken
shape.
Glass will hit theaters on January 18, 2019.
Eli
Writer David Chirchirillo contributed one
of the most brutally satisfying segments of
the 2014 horror anthology ABC's of Death 2.
And his screenplay for Eli garnered some attention
after making the 2015 Black List.
The film centers on a sick boy who experiences
ghostly goings-on at a secluded clinic, and
with Sinister 2's Ciaran Foy at the helm,
Eli could be a sleeper hit in the making.
Hellboy
Fans had long held out hope for a third installment
of director Guillermo Del Toro's Hellboy series,
but that hope was unfortunately dashed when
Del Toro finally admitted early in 2017 that
it just wasn't going to happen.
"Sorry, lady!"
But that doesn't mean moviegoers have seen
the last of the Right Hand of Doom.
Director Neil Marshall, best known for his
nerve-jangling 2005 thriller The Descent,
will be taking the helm of the R-rated reboot.
And Stranger Things' David Harbour has already
impressed with a first-glimpse of his physique
for the title role.
Count on having a hell of a good time when
Hellboy hits theaters on January 11th.
Untitled Jordan Peele project
Last but not least, Jordan Peele is returning
to the horror scene in 2019.
His directorial debut Get Out was one of the
most talked-about movies of 2017, so there's
a lot of excitement already building around
what he may do next.
Peele is expected to deliver another socially
charged horror film, and told ScreenJunkies:
"The worst monster that you can explore in
a horror movie is human beings themselves."
"I think the scariest thing we don't talk
about enough is that when people get together,
we're… capable of the darkest things."
Peele's new pic will drop on March 15th, 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!